>> JUAN AND I LOVE THAT SONG.
WELCOME BACK.
IT WOULD NOT BE "THE FIVE"
CHRISTMAS EVE SPECIAL UNLESS YOU
ARE HERE AND IF WE DIDN'T HAVE
TOYS.
WE SENT JESSE, JUAN AND GREG TO
CHECK OUT THE HOTTEST TOY
SELECTIONS.
WHAT IS THE WORST THAT CAN
HAPPEN?
>> WHAT ARE WE DOING HERE?
>> WE WILL PLAY WITH TOYS, GREG.
>> THIS IS A TYPICAL CLICHE
CHRISTMAS SEGMENT.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT?
>> YES.
>> THEY SEND YOU TO A TOY STORE
TO PLAY WITH TOYS OTHER STORES
HAVE ALREADY PLAYED WITH.
>> HOLY!
>> WHAT HAPPENED THEN?
>> WELL, IN NEW YORK THEY SAY
GREG GUTFELD'S GRINCHY HEART
GREW 3 SIZES THAT DAY.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THIS IS WHAT YOU ARE GETTING
ME.
>> MERRY CHRISTMAS, GREG.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> $800.
YOU CAN DO THAT.
>> THAT'S EXPENSIVE.
>> A WINTER WONDERLAND.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT I WANT I
WANT GLASS CLEANER AND LAUNDRY
DETERGENT.
>> JUAN.
>> ♪ ♪
>> CAN YOU MAKE JUAN DISAPPEAR?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> CAN YOU MAKE JESSE'S HAIR
STAND ON EDGE?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> PUT IT IN THE PALM OF YOUR
HAND.
WATCH CLOSELY.
THE MONEY JUMPS FROM YOUR HAND
THROUGH THE AIR.
>> OH!
>> HE HAS VERY SMALL HANDS.
>> A ROBOT THAT DISPENSES CANDY.
>> A BIG HERRIDGE -- HERSHEY
BAR.
>> ANOTHER ROBOT.
THEY ARE EVERYWHERE.
THEY ARE COMING TO TAKE OUR
JOBS.
IT'S ONLY A MATTER OF TIME,
AMERICA.
>> AND THAT'S VERY STRANGE.
>> ♪ ♪
>> MERRY CHRISTMAS TO ALL AND TO
ALL A GOOD NIGHT.
>> ♪ ♪
>> AH?
>> I LOVED IT.
>> GOOD JOB.
>> LOU DOBBS.
ANOTHER PRECISELY CAMEO.
-- PRICELESS CAMEO FROM LOU
DOBBS.
HE MAKES EVERYTHING.
>> THEY HAD THAT GIANT UNICORN?
>> I LEARNED IT'S GOOD TO BE
SHORT.
WHEN WE WALKED INTO THE TOY
STORY, THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T LIKE
JESSE CAN SEE JESSE BECAUSE HE
IS TALL.
THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T LIKE ME OR
YOU -- OR YOU WEREN'T THERE.
SOMEBODY GOES HI, JESSE AND
SOMEONE ELSE DROPS THE F-BOMB IN
A CHILDREN'S TOY STORE.
>> WERE YOU RUMMAGING THROUGH
PEOPLE'S POCKETS.
>> BEING THE LITTLE MAN I CAN, I
CAN STEAL.
>> WHY DIDN'T YOU MOUNT THE
UNICORN?
>> I THOUGHT YOU MEANT PUT IT ON
THE WALL.
>> $800 IS A LOT.
>> NOT FOR YOU DANA?
>> I WOULD NOT SPEND THAT?
>> I CAN'T WAIT FOR SECRET SANT.
>> WHAT DO YOU LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING ON CHRISTMAS TOMORROW?
>> OH, WE HAVE A NO GIFT PACT.
BUT I VIOLATED IT.
I SENT PETER A LINK TO A
BACKPACK PURSE I WANTED.
>> YOU DON'T LOOK LIKE SOMETHING
THAT WOULD WEAR A BACKPACK
PURSE?
>> YOU BROKE A CONTRACT?
>> YES, I MIGHT GO TO JAIL FOR 5
YEARS.
>> IN ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION,
WE GOT TO DANCE ON THAT PIANO.
>> YOU HAD SOME MOVES, JUAN.
>> GREG WAS NOT INTO IT.
>> THEY EDITED OUT WHAT I DID ON
THE PIANO.
[LAUGHING].
>> DOES THIS REQUIRE A MOP?
>> I BROUGHT IT DOWN TO A LOW
LEVEL.
>> I THINK IT WAS NICE THEY
ALLOWED US IN.
>> THAT WAS NICE.
IT'S JAM-PACKED.
IT'S NOT THE OLD STORE.
IT'S NEW.
>> THERE WAS A LINE.
BEING TV ANCHORS WE GOT TO CUT
IN LINE.
EVERYBODY IN LINE WAS HAPPY TO
SEE US.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
>> LIKE THE ILLEGALS.
THEY COME IN FRONT OF EVERYBODY
ELSE.